I think a B and C should be able to do
these pretty fast right I'm the boss on
the grass and so you spent the next ten
days going oh yeah you can really
quickly have a look at this by saying
well I know what the intercepts are
they're going to be negative two
negative three he's a little bit of a
dirty trick for you you know you're like
oh you're next instinct is I've got my
x-intercepts and I put my y-intercept so
on yeah don't do that just yet because
you put your wine to set somewhere and
in very inflated you'll make it very
difficult for you to like draw a pattern
curve it's gonna go through there for a
parabola you have the privilege of being
able to say actually whatever that
happens to be I'm just gonna make a
vertical scale 76 and you could just
read that off you okay so that makes
sense so that looked all right a lot
better than if you'd said or if that's
three that's six a bit be enough here oh
no I've got to redraw my axes are too
hot so here's our original graph now
frequently an extension to what you'll
encounter is they'll give you a printout
of the graph and then they will ask you
to transform it in some way on top of
the graph so that's what I am going to
do we already discussed what this would
do right we said that this was achieving
what kind of reflection I was going to
be vertical right so it's gonna go from
here down to here one of the nice ways
you can confirm that is when you have a
look at when you put in negative two
negative three
what happens when you start a minus sign
out the front well this all collapses to
be zero right
so that's why your exit sets they stay
exactly where they where they were fall
so I'm gonna get this graph you I've
missed a little bit
so this here is y equals negative f of X
or negative y equals f of X does that
make sense you can do the horizontal one
as well that's fine you can see it's
going to go all the way over to the
positive side to have roots of two and
three that's getting a B and C all right
now let's have a look at this you can
actually see because I've been a bit
sneaky I've actually already drawn all
the bits I need for this do you see
where they aren't so when you apply how
to do that think back you think back to
complex numbers when I said that a much
better definition for these things is
not just take the positive what it
really means is modulus how far you from
the origin does that make sense remember
that so the origin along here
remember these are all real numbers and
these are real numbers we're black on
the Cartesian plane again therefore when
I say for a point like this on my scale
that looks like the one thing okay when
I posed the question what's the absolute
value of that what I'm asking is how far
is it from its origin its origin has a
real number there so its distance is
four so that's why when I plot it it
just stays where it is but then when I
come to a point like this okay by the
way what is the what is the Y value
there
pretty sure it's negative 1/4 okay you
can go ahead and work that now
now I'm gonna pose the question what is
its distance from its origin and the
answer is well if I'm here at negative
water I go up here there I am one that
relaxes the distance is so that's why
you get this point up here and of course
you can connect the dots and that's why
you get this bouncy little thing because
you're constantly just asking what's the
distance okay now I pose this to you but
I gave you no sense of what that might
look like this is a bit trickier who's
got an idea what put you on the spot now
how many of you have an idea okay all
right so here's what I suggested let's
borrow something we understood from here
which is that if f of X is positive then
the absolute value of that is still
positive yeah so in other words wherever
f of X is positive as these plots on
here the graph remains unchanged yeah so
what does that mean here I'm gonna name
you said axis what that means is for all
the parts of that right that where X is
positive it's this part of the graph
right do you see that's the entire part
of the graph where X is positive degree
really for that
this is unchanged no change all right
now tell me what happens when I put
something negative in there if I were to
put in say like oh I don't know negative
2 if I put a negative 2 in to here
what's going to happen to that energy
it's going to become 2 so then this
becomes F of 2 now I can work out F of 2
is f of 2 is going to be 4 plus 10 plus
6 was 20 okay so it's like up here
somewhere
yeah this is that x equals negative 2 y
is going to be up here 20 how about x
equals 1 x equals negative 1 rather it's
getting a bit closer once you put X is
negative 1 into here absolute values
going to turn that into a 1 and then you
have to evaluate F of 1 which is 1 plus
5 plus 6 s 12 so in fact what you're
getting this is why it's under the
heading of reflection is this guy do you
see it
like over here it's behaving just like
this guy is right because absolute value
has ignored what's happening normal this
may be an extra stop okay you're right
who's got a graph for F it's got a graph
yeah can I see it so what I'm going to
do again is I'm just going to draw all
in f of X so here's my f of X now the
absolute value of y equals f of X here's
the first thing I'm going to know if I
say the absolute value of y is this then
I know you remember I said to you off
you put in a positive value inside these
absolute values then they could they
don't change if I put a negative value
here I put a negative value on the right
hand side what's gonna happen on the
left hand side what's gonna happen the
whole thing you're like oh wait the
absolute value of y like where is it
negative 1/4 right and the answer is
it's never negative 1/4 because this is
our C for a distance right so what this
means is anywhere this right-hand side
used to be negative those parts of the
graph don't exist anymore okay they
don't exist does that make sense because
you can't get a solution to this right
there's no y value you can stick in
there that's gonna give you that
so therefore what that means over here
is all these guys down here
they all cease to exist they're not
going to give you anything leave the
absolute value one can't possibly be
those now then to push on this a little
bit right here's what I've got I've got
the absolute value of y equals x squared
plus 5x plus 6 yeah now we're not used
to this doing this because we just think
of it as that bounty thing but the
absolute value function has a definition
right the absolute value of a is equal
to one of two things depending on what a
is if any positive then the absolute
value of a is just a remember we would
just say it doesn't change if on the
other hand the thing inside you know is
negative then what is the absolute value
may going to become maybe then you slap
this negative on it and double negatives
and that's what makes the poison
okay so what does it mean over here what
it means is that x squared plus 5x plus
6 is equal to one of two things
it's equal to something sometimes and
something else at different times
sometimes is equal to Y and sometimes
it's a - wine which one and win
I can follow this timeframe in fact is
literally exactly the same thing with
wise instead of eight okay the absolute
day why this thing is just Y if Y is
positive and look that's what I draw do
you see that this is y equals x squared
plus 5x plus 6 for y positive does that
make sense what about this when is a
negative Y if Y is negative so now where
is this where is this part of the graph
it's everything down here do you agree
this is where Y is less than 0 so can
someone tell me what does that thing
look like haven't you already drawn it
look yeah yeah yeah you drew this in
Part B but but but it's not not this top
part where do you agree with that
because that's not relevant you see that
so I'm just going to draw the bottom
parts of the red breath like this there
is bellend
that's the absolute value of y equals FX